[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Dienstag Norbert
Lehmann ist auch dabei für den Sport
das Leid in den Erdbebengebieten
übersteigt alle Vorstellungen sagt der
Bundespräsident
frieren kaum essen wenig Hoffnung von
den Erdbeben in der Türkei und in Syrien
sind 23 Millionen Menschen betroffen
immer mehr Tote werden geborgen
alles was helfen kann auch in
Deutschland wird dringend gebrauchtes
Material fürs Krisengebiet gepackt für
die Freiwilligen vor Ort beginnt ein
gefährlicher Einsatz
im Gespräch mit ukrainischen Soldaten
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
informiert sich in Kiel über die
militärische Situation und den Nutzen
deutscher Waffen
[Musik]
der zweite Tag nach der
Erdbebenkatastrophe der Schmerz ist
unbeschreiblich die internationale
Solidarität groß nach Angaben des
türkischen Präsidenten haben
mittlerweile 70 Länder Unterstützung
angeboten tausende Rettungskräfte aus
allen Teilen der Welt sind unterwegs
Hilfe ist dringend nötig schauen wir uns
die Dimensionen an
die Erdbebenregion im türkisch-syrischen
Grenzgebiet hat ein enorm großes Ausmaß
und ist dicht besiedelt insgesamt sind
wohl 23 Millionen Menschen betroffen
schätzt die Weltgesundheitsorganisation
die Zahl der bestätigten Toten liegt
inzwischen bei mehr als 6.000 und dürfte
weiter steigen mehr als 20.000 Menschen
sind verletzt luten leinhaus beginnt in
der Türkei
es ist die Stille der Helfer
sie wollen hören ob doch noch jemand
lebendig unter den Trümmern liegt
Adana 5 größte Stadt der Türkei das
Ausmaß der Katastrophe ist noch immer
nicht abzuschätzen ganze Familien sind
unter Schuttbergen begraben
der Sohn meines Cousins seine Frau sein
Vater seine Mutter der Onkel die Neffen
es fühlt sich sehr schlimm an
ein Hilferuf aus der Tiefe 280 km
östlich in adia
wo seid ihr antwortet der Mann und wird
zunächst ratlos er muss Hilfe holen und
wohl auch schweres Gerät
gleiche Stadt anderes Viertel sie hat es
geschafft einem Rettungsteam gelingt es
dieses verschüttete Mädchen aus einer
Spalte zu ziehen
von tausenden Toten spricht Präsident
Erdogan und ruft heute für das
Erdbebengebiet den Notstand aus
unser größter Trost ist das mehr als
8000 unsere Bürger lebendig aus den
Trümmern gerettet werden konnten
wie schlimm die Lage ist zeigen diese
Bilder aus hartei hier im äußersten
Süden der Türkei sind ganze Stadtviertel
zusammengekracht und der Containerhafen
im nahen ist genderun steht seit dem
Beben in Flammen
Erste Hilfe aus Deutschland sind
inzwischen im Katastrophengebiet
eingetroffen die Duisburger
Rettungsorganisation Isa wird mit
bergungshunden und Spezialgeräten
Überlebende suchen
zur Zerstörung kommt nun auch noch der
Schnee vor allem im nördlichen
Erdbebengebiet wie in Malatya wo erste
Zeltlager entstehen
wir haben versucht ein Zelt zu finden wo
wir bleiben können aber es sind keine
mehr da wir bitten dringend um
Unterstützung
Retter und Überlebende warten auf Hilfe
und ihnen läuft die Zeit davon der
türkische Wetterdienst hat weitere
Schneefälle vorhergesagt
schauen wir in die Nähe des Epizentrums
des Bebens nach göksun dort ist Anne
Brühl für uns eine wie ist die aktuelle
Situation gibt es noch Nachbeben
ja die gibt es und auch wir haben vor
einer guten Stunde eine schweres
Nachbeben hier erlebte hat gut eine
Minute die Erde gewackelt heute Nacht
kurz nach Mitternacht gab es hier ein
Nachbeben der Stärke 5,1 das andere
große Problem ist hier die Kälte es ist
eisekalt an eisiger Wind weht das liegt
Schnee die Temperaturen sinken auf -10
Grad und den Menschen hier den steht
jetzt eben die zweite Nacht in dieser
Kälte bevor die Menschen wollen
natürlich nicht in ihre Häuser
zurückkehren viele stehen zwar noch sind
aber durch das Erdbeben schwer
beschädigt immer noch nach Beben +
eisige Kälte wie kommen die
Rettungsarbeiten davor an
ja die laufen hier in der Region
wirklich erste langsam an hinter mir
werden gerade die Leichen von zwei
Frauen geborgen aus einem Haus das wird
vermutet dass noch sechs weitere Tote
unter den Trümmern liegen und die
Menschen hier in Götz und die haben
wirklich auf diese Hilfe gewartet als
wir heute Nachmittag hierher kamen über
einen verschneiten Bergpass da sind wir
vorbeigefahren an vielen LKW mit
schwerem Gerät
an türkischen Katastrophenschutz das
heißt die Hilfe die läuft jetzt hier
langsam an und die Menschen brauchen sie
auch wirklich dringend Generatoren sind
unterwegs hierher Zelten Decken
Öfen das wird hier sehr sehr dringend
gebraucht vielen Dank an der Brüder
das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aus technischen Gründen
aufgezeichnet in Syrien ist die
Situation der Menschen wohl noch weitaus
schwieriger denn in dem Bürgerkriegsland
fehlte es schon vor dem Erdbeben an
vielem jetzt hat sich die Lage im
Nordwesten noch mal dramatisch
verschärft auch weil kaum internationale
Helfer ins Land kommen und damit auch
keine Hilfsgüter die Menschen sind
überwiegend auf sich gestellt goline
berichtet
plötzlich bewegt sie sich doch
dutzende Kinder können die
zivilschutzhelfer der weißhelme retten
[Musik]
auch die kleine nur kann lebend geborgen
werden
immer noch hören die Helfer Rufe aus den
Trümmern aber die Zahl der eingestürzten
Häuser ist zu groß die Aufgabe zu
gigantisch für eine einzige kleine
Hilfsorganisation
wir brauchen im Moment alles wir
brauchen räumungsgerät sofortige
Unterstützung wir brauchen
internationale Rettungsteams sofortige
Hilfe
doch nichts davon ist hier bislang
angekommen im Gegenteil in einer Region
die schon vor dem Beben nur durch
Hilfslieferungen überlebte ist die
Lebenslinie der einzige Grenzübergang
zur Türkei aufgrund von zerstörten
Straßen derzeit abgeschnitten
die meisten der rund viereinhalb
Millionen Bewohner sind mehrfach
Vertriebene und Flüchtlinge zehntausende
haben nun erneut kein Zuhause
der Verlust hat mich gebrochen ich habe
keine Familie ich habe niemanden mehr
sagt ein Einwohner in genderis der 12
Menschen verloren hat
in den vom syrischen Regime
kontrollierten Gebieten wie hier die
Stadt Aleppo mangelte es auch vor dem
Beben an Treibstoff und Strom Damaskus
kündigte Treibstoff Hilfen an um die
Bergungsarbeiten voranzubringen in den
Städten Latakia und Hammer werden
hunderte immer noch vermisst
helfen das wollen auch viele Menschen
aus Deutschland neben den Ehrenamtlichen
Rettungskräften vom Technischen
Hilfswerk und anderen Organisationen
gibt es eine ganze Reihe von privaten
Initiativen die spontan auf die Beine
gestellt wurden vor allem auch von denen
die Angehörige und Freunde im
Katastrophengebiet haben Christian Volk
berichtet
hunderte Kartons packen Sie bei der
türkischen Gemeinde in Berlin zusammen
eine Hilfsaktion für die Erdbebenopfer
im Minutentakt kommen Decken Babynahrung
und Winterkleidung an das Gebäude
zeitweise so voll das kaum noch alle
Helfer hinein passen für viele ist es
eine Herzensangelegenheit ich Familie
die in der Nähe vom Katastrophengebiet
wohnt und die übernachten zurzeit halt
alle in Autos und versuchen auch da
wegzufahren ist halt alles etwas
schwierig auch im Ruhrgebiet die
Hilfsbereitschaft riesengroß in
Gelsenkirchen rufen zwei türkische
Unternehmer zu Spenden auf 2.000
Menschen kommen vorbei füllen in der
Nacht mehrere LKW mit dutzenden Tonnen
Hilfsgütern
wieder gesehen dass wir wirklich
Gemeinschaft zeigen und es geht gerade
nicht um die türkische Community hier
gibt es alle Nationalitäten hier gibt es
deutsche Russen wohnen alle
Nationalitäten und wir haben wieder
erkannt dass wir eins sind deutsche
Hilfsgüter werden wohl Tage lang
unterwegs sein doch Hilfe brauchte es
schnell deshalb macht sich auch das THW
auf den Weg im Gepäck Hoffnung im Moment
sind tatsächlich immer noch die Jugend
und Rettungsmaßnahmen
die wichtigsten Sachen weil die
Überlebenschancen einfach noch da sind
weil wirklich da noch lebende unter den
Trümmern sein können die wir natürlich
gerne suchen retten möchten und dann
ziehen viele selbstlos am Flughafen in
Istanbul ist es ein Wettlauf gegen die
Zeit hunderte wollen so schnell wie
möglich weiter in den Süden ins
Krisengebiet
wenn auch Sie den Menschen in den
Erdbebenregionen helfen möchten können
Sie spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die iban.de
65100 400
600-100-400-600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien alle Informationen gibt es
auch unter spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF
Text auf Seite 890 und direkt nach uns
sehen Sie um 19:25 ein ZDF Spezial zur
Katastrophe in der Türkei und in Syrien
zum Krieg in der Ukraine im Osten des
Landes im Don Bass toben weiter
erbitterte Kämpfe die ukrainische
Regierung spricht vom blutigsten Tag für
die russische Armee seit Beginn der
Invasion mehr als 1000 Soldaten sein
getötet worden unabhängig überprüfen
lassen sich die Angaben nicht zu Gast in
Kiew ist heute der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius Thomas
Reichert war dabei
der Gebhard Panzer aus Deutschland steht
an einem geheimen Ort am Stadtrand von
Kiew drei Raketen und eine Drohne die
auf die Stadt und ihre Versorgung
zielten erzählt die Besatzung habe sie
schon abgeschossen für
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
ist es der Moment daher der deutschen
Waffenhilfe für die Ukraine am aller
nächsten kommt wenn man hier steht und
das Material aus Deutschland sieht
wie großartig die ukrainischen Soldaten
und Soldaten ausgebildet werden sich
ausbilden lassen wie schnell sie in der
Lage sind das Gerät erfolgreich zu
bedienen mit großem Erfolg zu bedienen
ist das ein gutes ein gutes Gefühl das
zu sehen zuvor traf historius Soldaten
die jetzt nach Deutschland reisen zur
Ausbildung auf dem Leopard 2 die Truppen
kommen direkt von der Front ernste
Gesichter die kurz aufleuchten für ein
Foto Lächeln 14 Leopard 2 liefert
Deutschland und hofft dass andere Länder
folgen zusätzlich kündigt historis heute
die Lieferung von älteren Leopard 1
Panzern an ich kann die mitteilen dass
wir uns verständigt haben in einer
Gruppe verschiedene europäischer Länder
ein großes Kontingent von Leopard A1 zu
liefern das wird in Schritten in Etappen
erfolgen bis zum Sommer ca 20 25 im
Laufe des Jahres bis zum Ende des Jahres
bis auf 80 und vieles im Laufe des
ersten Quartal 24 dann auf über 100
Leopard eins zu kommen doch beim Treffen
mit Ukraine ist Präsidentin bei Gespräch
mit der Regierung in Kiew hört historius
auch weitergehen wir Wünsche Kampfjet
zum Beispiel
wir haben nicht über Namen oder Marken
gesprochen unsere Verbündeten und
Partner werden am Ende entscheiden
welche Plattform gut ist für die Ukraine
historius ist gegen Kampfjets die
Lieferung von Panzern zur Abwehr der
russischen Angriffe das sei erstmal
herausfordernd genug
Katrin Eugendorf in Kiew wie sehen die
Ukraine den Besuch des deutschen
Verteidigungsministers
also die ukrainische Regierung hat
diesen Besuch zunächst einmal als großen
Erfolg für sich verbucht was hier
besonders gut angekommen ist dass man
den Eindruck hatte dass der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister sich hier vor Ort
die Zeit genommen hat um sich ein Bild
zu machen so weiter das konnte dass er
auch mit Soldaten gesprochen hat dass er
sich angeguckt hat wie effektiv deutsche
Waffen hier eingesetzt werden können
auch wenn er nicht alle Forderungen der
Ukraine natürlich erfüllen will sehen
die Ukrainer hier ein Zeichen dafür dass
die Solidarität und Unterstützung doch
von Deutschland sehr groß ist die große
Frage ist aber jetzt natürlich werden
die anderen Europäer nachziehen also
wird diese sogenannte Panzer Koalition
von der hier die Rede ist im Prinzip
auch von den anderen europäischen
Partnern mitgetragen das ist eine Frage
die hier heute offen geblieben ist
Dankeschön Katrin Eigendorf live aus
Kiew
mit geballter Kraft setzen sich
Deutschland und Frankreich in Washington
gegen die Subventionspolitik der USA ein
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und sein
Kollege lümmer haben dort mit
Mitgliedern der US-Regierung gesprochen
die beiden kritisieren milliardenschwere
Subventionen ausschließlich für Firmen
die grüne Technologien in den USA
produzieren Europa befürchtet dass
europäische Unternehmen benachteiligt
werden oder Produktion in die USA
abwandert
fragen wir immer die Wissen in
Washington hat der Besuch der Minister
etwas gebracht
ich glaube ja Minister Habeck hat jetzt
gerade bei einer Pressekonferenz gesagt
der fördert vor allen Dingen das
gegenseitige Verständnis wo die Probleme
liegen und da geht es ja darum dass eben
amerikanische Firmen die hier herstellen
subventioniert und steuerlich gefördert
werden sollen man will das möglichst
viele europäische Unternehmen auch davon
profitieren und da gibt es zum Beispiel
bei Elektroautos eine Einigung die sich
zumindest abzeichnet das Autos die hier
in den USA geleast werden auch solche
Steuererleichterungen bekommen können
man hat sich darauf verständigt dass man
gemeinsam sich abstimmt in Bezug auf
seltene Rohstoffe die man fördern will
dass es ein zusätzliches Gremium gibt
dass sich darüber hin äh ihr austauscht
und dass man volle Transparenz haben
will welche Wirtschaftszweige werden
steuerlich subventioniert in den USA und
in Europa und das ist die Grundlage dass
die Europäische Union dann in den
nächsten Tagen wieder darüber
zusammensitzen kann um einen
Gegenvorschlag zu machen man will
Einigungen man will keine wet gab oder
keinen Wettkampf zwischen Europa und den
USA und ich glaube das ist das Ergebnis
von diesen Beratungen hier in Washington
die Einschätzung von MRT Wissen vielen
Dank nach Washington
in Deutschland hatten im vergangenen
Jahr viele Menschen wegen Lohnerhöhungen
mehr Geld auf dem Konto konnten sich
aber weniger davon kaufen laut
Statistischem Bundesamt sanken die real
Löhne in Deutschland zwar stiegen die
bruttomonatslöhne durchschnittlich um
3,4 Prozent die hohe Inflation von 7,9%
fraß das allerdings auf und führte
unterm Strich zu einem Reallohnverlust
von 4,1%
welche Branchen nach den jüngsten
Tarifabschlüssen wie viel mehr
lohnzahlen und was die
inflationsausgleichsprämie bringt das
können Sie in unserer ZDF heute App
nachlesen dort finden Sie auch weitere
Grafiken und Videos zum Thema
zusammengestellt von unseren
online-kollegen
RTL Deutschland hatte ja den Verlag
Gruner und Jahr mit vielen Zeitschriften
übernommen jetzt wird dort um und vor
allem abgebaut 23 Magazine sollen
eingestellt oder verkauft werden
darunter view oder geowissen
Flaggschiffe wie Stern Brigitte oder
Kapital bleiben bestehen durch die
Neuausrichtung könnten bis zu 700
Arbeitsplätze gestrichen werden dagegen
protestierten hunderte Mitarbeiter des
Verlagshauses die Gewerkschaften Verdi
sprach von einer fehlgeleiteten
Strategie des mutterkonzernsmann
es ist schon seltsam seit Jahren wissen
wir dass zu viel Zeit am Handy und im
Internet dem Selbstwert und der Seele
nicht wirklich gut tut und trotzdem
kommen viele kaum weg davon vor allem
aber längst nicht nur sind Kinder und
Jugendliche gefährdet gegensteuern soll
der heutige Safer Internet Day Anna duda
berichtet
Schule aus Handy an Instagram tiktok
Online Spiele aus dem Alltag von Tim
Lina und Larissa nicht mehr wegzudenken
wir kommen immer Videos die dich
interessieren egal du kannst weiter
scrollen es kommen immer Videos die dich
interessieren und das nicht wirklich ein
Grund aufzuhören also ich verliere mich
da komplett drinne und dann irgendwann
so nach einer halben Stunde merkt man
boah das das war jetzt einfach die Zeit
weg ja die ich eigentlich hätte nutzen
können für andere Sachen laut einer
vorsah Umfrage der EU-Initiative
klicksafe möchten 51% der 14 bis 17
jährigen eigentlich weniger Zeit am
Handy verbringen
57% haben Schwierigkeiten nicht aufs
Handy zu schauen und 75% der Eltern
möchten dass Ihre Kinder die Nutzung
digitaler Medien begrenzen beim Safer
Internet Day geht es darum die
Mechanismen in der digitalen Medien zu
begreifen nutzt das Netz das nettes
wunderbar aber lass dich nicht ausnutzen
vom Netz finde deine Grenzen und Rede
vor allem mit Freunde in rede mit deiner
Familie darüber was im Netz passiert
denn Kontrollverlust ist ein erster
Schritt zur Sucht mit Folgen soziale
Vereinsamung vor dem Gerät sozusagen
aber auch Schlaflosigkeit Gereiztheit
wenn man nicht konsumieren kann also so
etwas wie Entzugssymptome und damit es
nicht so weit kommt häufiger mal bewusst
das Handy weglegen
genau Handy weg und Fußball gucken zum
Beispiel DFB-Pokal Achtelfinale
zwei Partien heute Abend jeweils Zweite
Liga gegen erste Liga Sandhausen
empfängt Freiburg und Tabellenführer
Darmstadt der spielt in Frankfurt für
Unruhe bei der Eintracht sorgen
staatsanwaltschaftlicher Ermittlungen
gegen Präsident Peter Fischer
der Kokain von den Peter Fischers
Wohnung droht ein sportlich hochwertiges
Hessen Darby in den Hintergrund zu
drängen dann brauchst du jemand der zu
dir hält der und deswegen hatte hier
bete denke ich von allen die größte
Unterstützung im Verein beide Teams
haben einen Lauf die Frankfurter
profitieren von der Torgefahr ihres WM
Finalisten des Franzosen kolumani sie
gehören zu den Top 5 der Bundesliga
Darmstadt kommt mit beeindruckenden 20
Spielen ohne Niederlage der Zweitliga
Spitzenreiter hat bereits
Mönchengladbach aus dem Pokal geworfen
es ist in Derby es ist elektrisierend
für für viele Menschen hier in Hessen
elektrisieren ja zu Gewalttaten
animierend hoffentlich nicht
zur Ski Alpi WM in Frankreich nach den
Frauen gestern waren heute die Männer in
der Kombination dran ja und da gab es
einen Heimsieg der
franzosekunde Vorsprung
vortitelverteidiger Marco Schweiz aus
Österreich bester Deutscher Simon Jocher
auf Platz 13
und morgen beginnt die Biathlon-WM in
Oberhof mit 12 Wettbewerben den Anfang
macht die mixstaffel durchaus mit
deutschen medaillenschancen
Oberhof ist startklar für die heimwm der
Schnee ist da das deutsche Team gut
gelaunt und bereit von morgen an nach
Medaillen zu greifen das natürlich einer
der härtesten Wettkämpfe damit die
Mixed-Staffel sind wir da sind natürlich
die die Anzahl der Konkurrenten die
größten aber ja wir denke ich sind als
sieben gut drauf Olympiasiegerin Denis
hermannweg Zeit zu den Favoritinnen zwei
Weltcup Sieger bereits in dieser Saison
regelmäßig auf dem Podium bei
Staffelwettkämpfen gibt es auch
Medaillen Hoffnung für die deutschen
Männer absolute Favoriten allerdings die
Norweger mit dem großen Dominator
Johannes böhm
und der Auftakt mit der mixstaffel
Morgen bei uns im ZDF zu sehen ab 14:15
Uhr danke schön
nach eiskalter Nacht erwartet uns auch
morgen wieder ein sehr sonniger
Wintertag mehr zum Wetter gleich von
Katja horneffer Marietta Slomka begrüßt
sie um viertel vor zehn im heute-journal
und wir sagen danke und tschüss bis
morgen machen sie sich noch einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend wenn sie ganz genau
hinschauen dann sehen Sie wie dieses
kleine weiße Fleckchen sich auflöst ein
Nebelfeld in Norddeutschland Nebel gab
es auch Richtung Sachsen-Anhalt und
Thüringen die anderen weißen Flächen in
Deutschland die sie da sehen das ist
alles etwas Schnee heute Nacht ist es
meist klar und über Norddeutschland
gibt's mal ein paar Hochnebel Felder und
die Temperaturen werden eisig über
Schnee am alpenbrand droht strenger
Frost ist -14 Grad minus 1 - 2 Grad sind
es an den Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und
die Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei
-1 Grad am Alpenrand und plus 7 Grad am
Niederrhein und das wird morgen wieder
ein sehr sonniger Wintertag allenfalls
hier in Norden Schleswig-Holsteins
gibt's anfänglich noch so ein paar
Nebelfelder da und diese Sonne die
können Sie einfach ausnutzen eine
Sonnenbrandgefahr besteht wirklich nicht
das sehen Sie an diesen niedrigen Werten
für den UV-Index allerdings wird in
diesem Wetter was ändern denn schon am
Donnerstag und am Freitag gibt es in
Norddeutschland einige Regenschauer sehr
viel wird das nicht sein sonst bleibt es
winterlich es wird von Tag zu Tag aber
ein kleines bisschen milder war ein bis
zehn Grad am Samstag guten Abend